I suppose I should introduce myself
again this is the like advanced version
of the talk of the workshop how many
people weren't here in the last hour
okay we got we have a few we have a few
people know you were here arnould so
anyways we have a we have a few people
here who just arrived so real quick
before we go into any more detail did
anybody bring a device like at our
arduino or raspberry pi or anything okay
no problem just did just a quick
explanation this was this was originally
imagined as a as a workshop where you
would bring in devices and we would help
you with like projects and configuration
and stuff like that but we've got pretty
limited up t uptake on that so we're
going to try to turn into more of just a
sort of an in-depth show and tell and as
much as possible a question and answer
session like you know really we want if
anyone has any questions about anything
in the device realm you know just feel
free to ask us during this you know
during this presentation yeah so so one
of the things I'm going to initially go
over is some of the stuff a like more
in-depth on the device framework and
specifically with the Arduino device
driver so the device framework for those
of you who didn't just listen to me talk
about it in previous one the device
framework is new and mathematic at ten
point oh and allows you to basically
define driver classes for various
devices and so when you open when you
use functions like device open or device
read device configure those are all part
of the device framework and the device
framework functions operate on device
objects and classes before week until we
go any further just wanted to say once
more if you have any questions during
the session there there's no Q&A session
just raise your hand we will stop and go
over go into any topic on detail yes so
so yeah so that's kind of the device for
American the device framework
documentation is all inside Mathematica
10.3
or in the mathematica documentation
center including documentation on how on
on the Arduino itself so if you open up
the documentation center and the search
for arduino there's you know all kinds
of documentation on using device
configure and device read device it's a
right and etc but there's also
documentation on writing device drivers
themselves so this developing device
drivers page has all sorts of
information on defining all this kind of
stuff so you can look at examples on
this page of how to make new devices
basically and it's kind of expected that
you know in inside the language will
provide device drivers for stuff like
you know serial serial link which
connects to serial ports and stuff and
there's various advice low-level devices
like that but then you can also extend
those devices writing your own drivers
that kind of like you know inherit from
the super driver kind of and so the
Arduino driver is an example of that the
Arduino driver is a sub driver or
subclass of the serial link class so
because it uses my mic acting weird it
might be me okay okay anyways um and so
the so there's also documentation on the
serial driver so if we look at that you
know there's documentation on all the
drivers that are in mathematica and one
of the things that we wanted to do is we
want to develop the Arduino device
driver such that it would be easily
extendable right so as I was talking
about earlier is that we have all these
sorts of shields and stuff that the
community is built and that there's code
kind of backing these stuff and so the
idea would be we provide the Arduino
driver and then people can very easily
extend that to interface with other
devices sure and is there anyone here
who's not familiar with the Arduino yeah
I kind of jumped into that so right sure
okay good okay cool
sure so so kind of an overview of how
how you interact with the the Arduino is
the Arduino runs what's called a sketch
which is just like one likessee program
that gets compiled and uploaded to it
and so that so it's less like a
raspberry pi and that it has an
operating system it's more like like
like a watch or maybe like some sort of
automotive application where it just has
one program that's uploaded to it and it
just runs that program infinitely like
there's just a you know set of
instructions it runs and it just loops
that indefinitely like a computer from I
guess like the 80s or something anyway
so I would say you know me before that
yeah it's really it's really just a
micro it's really just a micro it's so
might get some microcontrollers the
distinction being is that when you when
you program like on the low level for
the Arduino you don't have access to
stuff like operating systems so there's
no concept of like a file system there's
no concept of anything and so or of any
like high level operating system
constructs and so it's just like you
access the registers and you know you
blow things into the ALU to add them and
stuff like that so it's very it's very
low level but you have you can get a
very fine-grained control over what you
can do and so for applications where
pulse width modulation is one specific
application and that's basically
emulating an analog voltage by switch
switching it on off at various
frequencies so to drive and this is
especially important in like driving
motors like on that robot is instead of
because Arduino can only output five
volts or zero volts it can only be on or
off however it can switch from being on
and off at a very high frequency and so
what it does is to the motors it will
just switch off and on really really
fast and so too the motors that the
motors get that same voltage but they
get less power and so that's how you can
kind of control the motor speed and
that's kind of a safer way to drive
motors than using some sort of other
like analog voltage or something and so
and so that's an example being able to
switch between the pin being on and
depend being off really really fast you
know we're talking about scale of like
let's see if I remember my SI prefix
nano second oh yes on the scale like
nanoseconds or something or microseconds
more more accurately but sure very very
quickly and so it'd be very impractical
to do it on a device like a raspberry pi
because there's all sorts of like
background stuff that Linux is runnings
and so you might be trying to you know
turn the pin on and then one day a no
second later you want to turn it off
well in that nanosecond Linux might be
like well hey i'm going to interrupt you
and do whatever else you know front end
or terminal or whatever on the Arduino
none of that exists you have like full
control over that right so basically you
know just just to continue on that point
and forgive me for anyone who was here
before it's about time it's about
dealing with timing that's the
difference between dealing with a full
computer device like a like a raspberry
pi you know or a BeagleBone black and
something like a microcontroller if your
application is time critical and that's
very important for things that read and
write two devices where you know you
might need to respond within a certain
amount of time or if you don't
continuously read at a certain frequency
you know you might like lose information
or miss something you know there's so
that I can quick over some of the the
device doesn't connect my device project
sure let me quick pull up there we go
places so the connected devices project
basically let me make this a little bit
larger is a collection of things or air
collection of information like you know
spec sheets and stuff that has been kind
of aggregated into there's there's
there's a short answer to his question
though oh okay sorry sorry sorry so the
short answer to your question is that we
absolutely plan to put more information
for the kinect for the device framework
itself on to hear that it can consume
but at the moment it's more of just a
gregation of information that that a
context hasn't been added yet but there
are many active ideas about what sort of
information we can add to this that will
make that useful but I mean I think
that's probably an early thing we could
add to it is information about
interfaces you know what can you
actually connect to what I think that
you know things like that might be
useful information so yeah it's it's an
unfinished picture right now so they're
very a few one place to look for like
device drivers developed by the
community would be the Wolfram community
which is like kind of like a forum and
so there's I've seen a few different
device drivers released on there but
another thing that we're doing soon then
I think will be relevant to that is the
Wolfram marketplace we kind of view the
Wolfram marketplaces like a way for
people to you know kind of bring their
little wool firm applications and they
you know maybe like it's an algorithm
for some physics thing or whatever that
they want to kind of sell in the market
place well that would be a great place
for device drivers to live as well so if
you know people start developing lots of
advice drivers and they want to you know
kind of share it the Wolfen marketplace
is a place it right we might just end up
throwing some more stuff on github to
just you know things like things like
you know arduino code we're actually
planning on putting some Arduino code
you know support code for the Arduino
Arduino pacolet on to github so that we
can hopefully get some more people you
know just throwing in some library
symbol library drivers and stuff where
it might be useful to them I think some
collaboration would go a long way there
right now in the release version of
Mathematica know that it's not true
however in the next in mathematica 11 is
what we're shooting for then we'll have
support for like devices like the UN
that I showed a while ago and like some
of this more experimental stuff right
there are some arduino like devices such
as the you near that have they are
actually computers with networking and
all of that stuff and they have the
arduino microcontroller connected on the
board so you can actually get kind of a
total package and we are working to do
some support functions to make it so you
can automatically configure the network
connectivity and stuff when you set it
up so yeah yeah that's another thing
that we're exploring XP is a really for
those of you not familiar XB XB is a
wireless like well the protocol is
zigbee but XP is like the implementation
it's a specific device that communicates
wirelessly it's made for like you know
distributed sensor network so like say
you're you know out you know you want to
measure the humidity of various plants
in a giant field you might have you know
humidity sensor every 30 feet or
something distribution across the giant
field well all of those things might not
have a direct Wi-Fi connection and
instead they're going to have like
zigbee connections amongst each other
and then that's how they're going to you
know talk back with the note and that
and that's another thing that we're
exploring is a zigbee link but one way
that you can integrate like zigbee into
mathematica is their libraries that
people have written for interfacing
zigbee with mathematica and so you plug
in arduino zigbee with arduino sorry so
you plug the XB into the arduino and
arduino into mathematica and then that
XB you upload the XP library and have
whatever XP devices out and you know
your sensor network or whatever and you
can kind of interface with it that way
that's a typical application I mean does
anyone want an explanation of the
connected devices project I mean we can
go in-depth on that too i mean it's some
of the cool things about the connected
device of devices project is that all of
these different devices all this one
doesn't have very much so the purpose of
the connected devices project is to
aggregate all this information about all
sorts of different devices and so you
look at what i was trying to get the
devices and then get everything into the
system and then come up with use cases
second we're starting off with a large
corpus of data and then
we're working backwards from there so
you know where we're in the collection
phase the context is weak so so the
general idea of this will be that
eventually all of this information like
the fact that this is power source by to
triple-a batteries that's all
information that we would want to tie
into something like Wolfram Alpha that
you could use from Mathematica so the
idea would be like you have you know you
by your sensor or whatever you have it
like sitting on your desk and in
Mathematica you could just you know that
would that could be an entity and you
could query properties about that and
like maybe you know load a device driver
or something from that and that would
all be curated through the device the
connected devices project and what I was
trying to find an example of is an
example of a device that has lots of
different like interfaces and stuff and
so this one there's just like some
information on the basic like height and
stuff right so another goal of this is
to try to come up with a number of
actual things that can be measured
physical quantities that can be measured
and understood because having
information about everything in the
world that measures the quantity or
measures some sort of piece of data and
just being able to know what can be
measured and how much you know actually
does that is information we can use in
the future too okay sorry so here's an
example of a device this is a
temperature sensor that we have in the
connected devices project so you can see
it measures all measures both the
temperature in community I guess but it
measures relative humidity and
temperature and so if we click on those
that will show you like all you can kind
of see these almost look like entity
objects and you can see all these other
sensors that measure that same thing and
so that's kind of like the idea of that
we want to bring in after we've like
finished curating more of this data and
integrate it into the system is you know
make all this kind of computable rain
knowing how much a machine can actually
know about the physical world you know
that that starts as a giant collection
process yeah you work backwards from
there yeah so so that's kind of like a
introduction to the connected devices
project I remember I want to circle back
a little bit there's question earlier
about like the big picture how the
Arduino interfaces with with Mathematica
so you have Mathematica and the Arduino
runs what's called a sketch and that
sketch communicates over like over the
USB cable like this just to which
basically is turned into a serial
connection but it's you have the
physical cable which communicates with
the sketch that the Arduino is running
and so when you deploy a function to
that that sketches I customized to
include that function and that there's
like a mini kind of you can think of it
like a mini evaluator loop that sits on
the Arduino that waits for a quest to be
sent from Mathematica to the Arduino and
then interprets those does whatever it
wants or does whatever is requested and
then sends the you know response back
over over the wire connection to
Mathematica it's important to note that
if you're using our generated sketch
yeah we do some rough scheduling there
so that means that you know there is if
you are extremely time-sensitive yeah
that will be that will be you know
something that will act well the the
scheduling that the alex is talking
about is something like kind of more
from a high level so in Mathematica
there's this concept of a scheduled task
right so you can schedule a task to run
that I don't know would I you know
calculate financial data and like
generate a port report right so you can
have these schedule tasks that run
there's an analog of that that runs on
the Arduino so that you can schedule
tasks that the Arduino runs itself and
the Arduino does that independently of
Mathematica and so an example of that
the the Arduino itself has like a
register that is incremented after each
instruction and that's like a hardware
thing and so you can kind of figure out
you can't figure out an absolute time
like oh it's 206 but you can figure out
it's been you know three thousand
milliseconds since I turned on right I
think that with something like that I
would not expect that to do hard you
know real-world timing I think it's you
know in a lot of embedded hardware
that's a really difficult problem to
solve and I think that something low end
like an Arduino is unlikely to get that
perfectly accurate all right go ahead so
the sketch that you yeah yeah the the
sketch that is deployed is actually
inside you can look at it in the
mathematical layout let me show you how
to find that let's do it yeah that's
that's what we're here for this is why
it's the advanced you
section here applications so my
applications show up set the your user
implications or is that the one on your
desktop that's the user applications oh
well I guess you can do that too it just
give it a second my mac is having some
it's it's a little usually there's
things on your heart yeah usually
there's data on the hard drive i don't
know but maybe i'm not a big mac person
oh wait okay no there no other one there
we go okay all right i got from here
okay so now we'll go into applications
cute I'll do y'all do 10 and so you can
show the package contents in Windows you
go under like c program files etc can we
make this bigger at all I don't know
it's under links so you'll go in the
mathematical layout and then under
system files and then you under links
and then under arduino link and then
under resources and the sea source and
then the sketch template it's it's the
sketch template isn't like valid c c++
code because there are parts that are
like templated that you have to
configure all right so i make this
larger can I just scroll and like this
okay I don't know how to make this
lecture you
zum-zum there we go that's not what I
wanted oh no you know what it's a pretty
big screen let's just pretend they okay
so just give quick okay all right okay
so this is this is the sketch and the
the sketch communicates with mathematica
using a protocol called Fermata in
Fermanagh is like an open source
protocol you can go and github and see
other fermata implementations this is a
specific one that we did for this and
kind of customize it a little bit but
firm on is basically just like another
protocol that says you know the the
order of bits means blah or whatever
it's just a protocol and there are
various other devices that support the
fermata protocol but basically how it
works is you have the so you have your
void setup function and you know if
you've ever used arduino there are two
like functions that you have to have an
Arduino sketch there's the setup
function in the loop function so the
setup function when you first run it
that get when you first turn on the
Arduino the setup function is run and
then loop function is run once and it
goes and then it starts running the loop
again it just loops you know that's what
the loop function does right and some
some explanation of why we have a
complicated you know system here is both
to define a language for the colonel to
speak to the Arduino that's consistent
you know as something that's where its
industry standard so people can actually
understand the way we're communicating
yeah in addition to that just to
simplify the task of oftentimes the most
common thing someone's going to want to
do is they're going to want to take this
Arduino they're going to want to plug it
in and they're going to want to just say
i want to read what's on this bin i want
to read the note the voltage I want to
read whether it's on or off and that's
the kind of decision making i'm going to
deal with this device so scheduling
those reads of those rights is the main
purpose of that sketch so yeah research
right so the ok so the wild one is an
infinite loop the reason that i have the
infinite loop inside that is because
it's a little bit i mean i could have
also just used a loop and then going to
continue but there's it's a little bit
simpler to use a wild one the cool the
core of your operating system has this
there isn't some place in your operating
system there is
endless loop the you know with some
interrupts that it's listening for and
stuff like that but that's the core I
mean when you have no operating system
some there needs to be some sort of
thing moving that loop there's some
stuff that the Arduino software does
like behind the scenes in between your
loop calls and I like do that myself in
my own I like kind of customize that and
so I don't want it to exit the loop
function and start to do that stuff
because I want to like manage the serial
buffer and all that stuff myself with a
sketch but but the the basic idea of
this sketch is that it starts running it
goes into this while 1 loop and then it
waits for tasks to be sent it'll read
the task and then it will queue up that
task and then if you know if there are
multiple things in the queue it'll run
the most recent one and that's how its
schedule things and so you can set it up
so that the Arduino will add to that Q
and then it will you know run the tasks
in the cube right and there's some
lessons to be had here about having
devices interact with the mathematica
colonel because you know it it has a
it's not real time and you know it is a
value in there is an evaluator that you
know is happening and some as moving in
an uncertain speed and you know if that
device is sending information then there
has to be some sort of queuing the yasm
okay so if you wanted I can I could
quick show you creating a sketch yeah so
so if you want to use so the you'll run
device open in the device framework that
will open the connect the serial
connection to the sketch now if you want
to customize that and like add your own
functions do that what you do is you use
device configure and there are various
options that you can run with the vice
configure so one of them is the
functions option and so the functions
option actually I have this in the
notebook later on so so the functions
option takes various different in this
notebook i'm showing is unpassable if
you go on my talk the arduino talk from
earlier this morning this notebook is
there and there's stuff on that but
basically you can run device configure
of the device class and then upload and
then that goes to a list of options that
configure the sketch and so here I just
have one option which is functions and
so you can add as many functions as you
need
and so here the functions goes through
an association and the association is of
the name of the function you want to
call it and then the arduino code like
symbolic wrapper that takes an
association which describes the arduino
code so this Arduino code tater this
Arduino code function takes in two real
arguments and returns back one real
argument and the code for that is just
this raw this is the string right here
and so that that's just straight C C++
code so you write a valid C C++ function
stick it in the code key for the
Association and then you run this and it
will upload that so I can quick upload
that if I see ya I still have it open so
I can run that actually I didn't I don't
think I had it open hold on let me open
the device again sure okay and you know
an important thing to know is while
though while your code is running you
should still be able to read and write
from pan things like that we did that
that is part of why we have you know a
simple schedule simple scheduling on the
Arduino is to continue to enable that
functionality even when it's running
your code
that's that's it that's almost exactly
what Ian did earlier the you with the
you and yes he actually that wasn't
doing that was during the prior talk but
he when he got this thing connected to
the wireless the way he did it was he
essentially packed some information
about the networking under the sketch he
deployed it from a USB cable to the
device that when he unplugged it and it
rebooted it connected to the network so
and that could be an internet connection
if that if the network gets on has
internet access that could do you know
data drop or we are going to add data
drop functionality think you to network
Arduinos as well so it should be as
simple as you know just telling it to
read this read this pin and write it to
this data to do this data bin yeah
that's all planned functionality but
kind of going back to the configuring
the sketch so to configure the sketch
you just use the vice configures as
explaining and that uploads this
function I just called it single blink
and that single blink function we can
execute that I'm not going to point this
at somebody it's kind of right that
turns on the LED which you can't see
because this isn't plugged in yes yeah
it's just a simple LED that I blinked on
with with that function so if i run it
again it'll blink off again oh my still
don't have it trying to bring up the
presenter
okay so so that's just a live feed of
that and so if i run this function again
it'll blink that on and running it again
blinks it off so what that's doing is
that sending a task to the arduino
sketch it gets queued up and then it
runs this this void blink function right
here that gets run so but the scheduling
part that we've been talking about is
that you can schedule that task to be
run with on the Arduino so the Arduino
schedule is so the the options to this
are in the documentation center and you
can redo the different time specs it's
almost exactly similar as run scheduled
task just need to change this quick this
is slightly different so this runs every
one second for a total of six times it
will run that blink task and you'll
notice that there's well you can't
really see this but there's no
communication that actually happens so
that scheduling is entirely independent
of mathematica you know I can schedule
it again and there's no serial
communication so I could quit the
mathematica colonel right now and then
that would continue to be scheduled but
we can also schedule it to be like
infinitely scheduled oops and so
scheduling one just means run this
function every one second and tell the
end of time basically and so but while
that's happening yep no I think I was
off okay that can be disconnected from
the colonel and you know we'll continue
running that's important for when you
want to define some sort of task that
might be either communicating directly
with the cloud you know it's not
actually communicating with an active
kernel or something that you know you
just want to run on the field and
collect data from later right right so
so we schedule this infinite task to run
and that's being run on the Arduino but
due to the like the scheduling
algorithms we implement it it can also
do other stuff wallets scheduling that
and so here I can continue to read from
the analog pin which just doesn't have
anything connected so it's kind of a
meaningless voltage but you can imagine
like scheduling some sort of task
to run every second but then you can
still do other stuff like reading and
writing from the pins on the Arduino and
you can also do stuff like device read
time series to read that and it will
continue to communicate while that other
thing is being scheduled so you know
there's a date list plot of the past
three seconds value for the analog pin
but basically what what this really
enables you to do is you can deploy to
the Arduino or you know we're other
devices as well you'll be eventually
able to do that right now it's kind of
just there do we know deploy functions
that are scheduled themselves and so the
Arduino is doing the scheduling and so
you can disconnect it and go put it out
in the field and it will do whatever you
know upload the data data drop or
control some sort of motor or something
and it just as I asynchronously from
Mathematica so you can use Mathematica
just set up the device to do whatever
you need to do disconnect it and go you
know go on your merry way so there's a
few different models that we have for
for scheduling things on the Arduino
right now what it's doing is an infinite
scheduling and so it scheduled
infinitely you just specify the the time
differences between when each task is
run and so it's very similar to a
scheduled task on Mathematica so if I do
run scheduled task of I don't know print
date string and then I say one every one
second that will print off the date
where's my messages we do there we go so
you can see down here it's printing off
the date every second and so a similar
thing is happening on the Arduino it'll
kind of wait it's not just like a
blocking wait it'll kind of countdown on
a timer until that elapses when it
counts down then it runs the function
and then when it returns from the
function that timer starts again and but
during that timer it's not just sitting
there doing nothing it's waiting to see
if it hears if it gets any new tasks
from Mathematica during that time and so
that's what enables us to do stuff like
like this device retime series that i
just did
so what's happening is it'll turn it'll
run the blink function and then during
the timer the timer is one second as we
uploaded during that one second you know
all these new requests to read from
analog pin a zero from the device time
read series those are being sent and it
responds to those because it's just
sitting there waiting so if you
disconnect that from power or
disconnected from the colonel and then
reconnect it with power will it will it
jump straight into this sketch if if you
disconnect it if you disconnect it from
the colonel and that you quit
Mathematica but the Arduino maintains
power it will keep running however if
the Arduino loses power you need to send
that task again to tell it to schedule
that we're currently working on a way to
have it so that it knows what to do when
you start when it starts itself up and
so that it can maintain that state
across power loss but there's some
intricacies related to that when you
connect it back up again mathematica
doesn't know what kind of Arduino or
like what sketch is running and so yeah
you kind of have to start all over again
but just to demonstrate this if I quit
the with the local kernel on Mathematica
so now there's no longer a connection to
the Arduino you can still see it's still
blinking away yeah exactly the Arduino
the Arduino was given its task and then
now it's listening for new tasks and
until it here is a new task it's just
going to continue to do that and how do
I not quit at the colonel and it but I
still wanted to stop it you can delete
the task with device execute delete task
here question so if you restarted the
colonel what you could do is there's
actually a device execute of software
reset so you can run so if I open up
another connection what is the name of
this
think it's let me quick check 1411
so and actually in the device open
sequence it sends a reset signal and so
but if you opened it up again you can do
if you do device execute Arduino
software reset that will reset the
Arduino from like that so so for some
reason if you upload code or a function
that just you know you know you wrote
you have an infinite while loop or
something and it gets stuck or something
happens you can reset the Arduino from
the something you can software reset it
from Mathematica if you know in that
doesn't like break the connection that
just sends the bootloader because
there's like a little watchdog that
listens for you know upload commands and
you just send like an upload command
with no data and it's like oh I'm going
to upload and then it doesn't get
anything so it just resets so yeah some
work has gone into making sure you can
always recover from whatever state the
Arduino is in exactly exactly ok maybe
we certainly could ok mr. does anyone
have any before we move on we're we're
going to show a slightly more
complicated demo that use it that where
we do we have a robot here that uses a
Raspberry Pi and an Arduino in
conjunction but does anyone have any
other general questions about you know
arduino or raspberry pi or any of our
you know devices in general currently
currently know that the best way to get
like a digital analog converter is to
you know buy a little chip and hook it
up to an arduino and then interface with
the arduino but that's the simple that's
the router out of least resistance i
think right i mean you're getting a
quick and dirty serial interface to
anything that you connect to an arduino
that's that's really the cheapest way to
get you know random sensor data into the
kernel so so yeah there's ya doing USB
like direct USB devices like that gets
complicated because you know the USB
code that you would bright is different
than like on linux than it is on you
know mac or you have to do with device
drivers like actual os-level driver
which you know is very system dependent
well I mean it could be less complicated
too if you have a user space if you've
like a library like a C library that
does it you you actually can write some
pretty simple wrapper code that links
against it and you could use that and
load that into the kernel so if you're
feeling particularly enterprising about
connecting it it's not terribly
difficult to do especially if it if
there's a time-sensitive connection
between the kernel and if it just needs
to you know read a value from it you
know with note with know what time where
time is not a factor yeah it only gets
complicated when time is a factor and
you have to do it in a separate thread
yeah then you have to deal with
asynchronous tasks and all that all that
good stuff are you want a Harold set the
camera up over here so this this demo is
basically an example of a more advanced
use case or basically connecting
different devices together using the
colonel on a Raspberry Pi which is
basically running the same Arduino code
that Ian's been showing here in order to
deploy a sketch and we are using a
separate colonel yet on his laptop to
generate a sketch to generate a set of
coordinates that it's going to use to
draw a picture and we're taking
basically wolfram alpha is popular curve
data so things like stephen wolfram
curve Otto Otto von Bismarck curve you
know as the input we're doing some
Pokemon drawings here but and we're
basically turning that into a drawing
that this robots going to draw
yeah I should be able to see it on the
video there I can zoom in a little bit
more parametric curves stored I'll
rotate this suit the button is in
several steps or several hundred fairies
they combined into one big I maintain so
in order to find the path between those
additional code to kind of find the
endpoints of those curbs and paths
between them and normally we have the
pendant
yeah a physical thing gets physical
things have problems we hardware is hard
yeah all its all side effects for us so
all right but it's just the example we
wanted to give though is basically like
a system where you have to two Colonels
communicating in addition to an Arduino
three separate computers being used in
order to complete a task with a robot
I'm just going to show the Pikachu curve
that it drove yeah we're very lucky with
me from alpha before it isn't well I was
everyone oh you're on yeah so this is
the go away this is the curve that it
was trying to draw and I will show you
the curva true right
so before we had this set of the
tropical spaces
right but you know so the important
thing here though is part of the now you
know using these different systems is
the goal is you're always going to have
situations where you have unequal
amounts of computing power on different
devices and figuring out which computers
should run which task is actually a
really important problem and something
that would usually play into this if you
had a good internet connection would be
cloud computing that you can always have
a very very computationally intensive
task being handled by you know some
server in the internet somewhere and you
know you can have less computationally
intensive but still computationally
intensive tasks occur on a small device
like a raspberry pi and then tasks that
are simple and mechanical occurring on
an Arduino that sort of partition system
model is very much like a front brain
back brain kind of model and if you want
to do very advanced stuff with robots or
devices then you know that's a sort of
system you need to create some sort of
software and that that's especially
important with things like look for take
drones for instance with a drone you
know you have a lot of you know
differential equations and stuff
required to keep that thing afloat you
know when it's dealing with wind
resistance and things like that and at
no point do you want some application
sitting in a Linux partition to block it
for a second and have it you know not
adjust for the wind and flip out and
crash or something like that so you end
up with this partition system model
we're sort of mocking that model up with
this robot by showing a microcontroller
system that's real time communicating
with you know a raspberry pi that is
very very not real time right yeah yeah
the the serial communication in the
Arduino driver of the device framework
is the ms1 connections you have the
Arduino which is physically connected to
all the motors and then Arduino and then
through Arduino link you have the
Raspberry Pi and then through what's
called launch manager or the network
connection basically you have it
connected to you know your desktop
computer and then ideally you know you
have another link to the Internet and
you have your cloud servers and
and all sorts of stuff but when we made
this demo we made it for a location that
would not have reliable internet so we
did not include the cloud in this demo
but well yeah okay so any final
questions yeah questions in general too
I mean you guys have any questions about
anything we've gone over okay so i think
more all right that we have four minutes
and 49 seconds left so i'll just say you
know thank you guys very much for your
time